so a lot of people ask me
that are a little bit tangential to
the programming the computing world and
they're interested to learn programming
like all kinds of disciplines that are
outside of the particular discipline of
computer science
what advice do you have for people that
want to learn how to program
or want to either taste
this little skill set or discipline
or try to see if it can be used somehow
in their own life
what stage of life are they in uh
it feels one of the magic things about
the internet of the people that write me
is i don't know because my answer is
different for
for my daughter is taking ap computer
science right now
hi johnny um she's uh she's amazing and
doing amazing things and
my son's beginning to get interested and
i'll be really curious where he takes it
i think he's
his mind actually works very well for
this sort of thing and she's doing great
but one of the things i have to tell her
all the time she points well i want to
make a rhythm game
so i want to go for two weeks and then
build a rhythm game show me how to build
a rhythm game
and start small learn the building
blocks and howard take the time
have patience eventually you'll build a
rhythm game i was in grad school
when i suddenly woke up one day over the
royal east
um and i thought wait a minute i'm a
computer scientist i should be able to
write pac-man in an afternoon and i did
not with great graphics it was actually
very cool game i had to figure out how
the ghost moved and everything and i did
it in an afternoon in pascal
on an old apple 2gs um nice but if i had
started out
trying to build pac-man i think it
probably would have ended very poorly
for me luckily back then
there weren't you know these magical
devices we call phones and
software everywhere to give me this
illusion that i could create something
by myself from the basics inside of a
weekend like that
i mean that was a culmination of years
and years and years right before i
decided i should be able to write this
and i could so you know my advice if
you're early on is
you know you've got the internet there
are lots of people there to give you the
information
find someone who cares about this
remember they've been doing it for a
very long time
take it slow learn the little pieces get
excited about it and then
keep the big projects you want to build
in mind you'll get there soon enough
because as a wise man once said life is
long
sometimes it doesn't seem that long but
it is long and
you have enough time to to build it all
out it all the information is out there
but start small you know generate
fibonacci numbers
that's not exciting but it'll just
well there's only one programming
language it's lisp but if you have to
pick
a programming language i guess in
today's what would i do i guess i do
python is basically doing this but with
with better syntax
blasphemy yeah see with c syntax how
about that
so you're going to argue that c syntax
is better than anything
anyway also i'll go i'm going to answer
python despite right now tell me tell
your story about the
somebody's dissertation that had a lisp
program in it it was so funny
this is uh this is dave's dave's
listener dave mcallister who's a
professor at mit for a while and then he
came in our inner girl labs
now he's at um now he's a technology
technical institute of chicago
uh a brilliant guy uh such an
interesting guy anyway his thesis
uh it was a theorem proverb
and he decided to have as an appendix
uh his actual code which of course was
already in list because of course it was
and like the last 20 pages are just
right parentheses
this is wonderful like they that's
programming right there
pages of book pages of right parentheses
anyway lisp is the only real language
but i understand that that's not
necessarily the place where you start
python is just fine nah python is good
if you're you know of a certain age if
you're really young and trying to figure
out
graphical languages that let you kind of
see how the thing works and that's fine
too they're all fine it almost doesn't
matter but there are people who spend a
lot of time
thinking about how to build languages
that get people in
the questions are you trying to get in
and figure out what it is or do you
already know
what you want and that's why i asked you
what stage of life people are in because
if you're different stages of life you
you would you would attack it
differently the the answer to that
question of which language keeps
changing i mean there's some
value to exploring uh a lot of people
write to me about julia there's there's
these like more modern languages they
keep
being invented rust and and kotlin and
there's stuff that uh for people who
love
functional languages like lisp that
there apparently there's echoes of that
but much better
in the modern languages and it's
worthwhile to uh
especially when you're learning
languages it feels like it's okay to try
one that's not
like the popular one oh yeah but you
know i think you get that
you get that way of thinking almost no
matter what language
and if you if you push far enough like
it can be assembly language
but you need to push pretty far before
you start to hit the really deep
concepts that you would get sooner in
other languages
but like i don't know computation is
kind of computation this kind of
touring equivalent is kind of
computation and so it's so
it matters how you express things but
you have to build out that mental
structure in your mind
and you i don't i don't think it's super
matters which language
i mean it matters a little because some
things are just at the wrong level of
abstraction i think assembly's at the
wrong level abstracts for someone coming
in new
um i think that if you start someone
coming in new
yes for frameworks big frameworks or or
quite a bit um you know you've got to
get to the point where i want to learn
any language means i just pick up a
reference book and
i think of a project and i go through it
in the weekend right you got it you got
to get there you're right though
the languages that are designed for that
are it almost doesn't matter pick the
ones that people have
built tutorials and infrastructure
around to help you get kind of
kind of eased into it because it's hard
i mean i did this little experiment with
um i was teaching intro to cs in the
summer as a favor
uh which is anyway i was able to make
your memories
i was teaching intro to us as a favor it
was very funny because i'd go in every
single time and i would think to myself
how am i possibly going to fill up an
hour and a half talking about for loops
right
and there wasn't enough time it took me
a while to realize this right
there are only three things right
there's reading from a variable writing
to a variable and conditional branching
everything else is syntactic sugar right
the syntactic sugar matters but that's
it
and when i say that's it i don't mean
it's simple i mean it's hard
like conditional branching loops
variable
those are really hard concepts so you
shouldn't be discouraged by this here's
a simple experiment
i'm going to ask you a question now you
ready x equals three
okay y equals four
okay what is x three what is y
four y equals gonna mess this up no
that's oh it's easier
y equals x y equals x what is y
uh three that's right x equals seven
what is y that's one of the trickiest
things to get
for programmers that there's a memory
and the variables are pointing to a
particular
thing in memory and sometimes the
languages hide that from you and they
bring it closer to the way you think
mathematics works right so in fact
mark gusdale who worries about these
sorts of things or used to worry about
these sorts of things anyway
had this kind of belief that actually
people when they see these statements x
equals something y equals something y
equals x
that you have now uh made a mathematical
statement that y and x are the same
which you can if you just put like an
anchor in front of it yes but
people that's not what you're doing yeah
right i thought
and i kind of asked the question and i i
think had some evidence for this i'm
hardly a study
is that most of the people who didn't
know the answer weren't sure about the
answer
they had used spreadsheets ah
and so it's a it's a na it's it's it's
you know
um it's by it's by reference or by name
really
right and so depending upon what you
think they are you get completely
different answers
the fact that i could go or one could go
two thirds of the way through a semester
and people still hadn't figured out in
their heads
when you say y equals x what that meant
tells you it's actually hard
because all those answers are possible
in fact when you said oh if you just put
an ampersand in front of it i mean that
doesn't make any sense for an intro
class and of course a lot of language
don't even give you the ability to think
about it in terms of ampersand
do we want to have a 45-minute
discussion about the difference between
equal eq and equal
in lisp i know you do
but you know you could do that it's this
is actually really hard stuff
so you shouldn't be it's not too hard we
all do it
but you shouldn't be discouraged it's
why you should start small so that you
can figure out these things you have the
right model in your head
so that when you write the language you
can execute it and build the machine
that you you want to build right yeah
the funny thing about programming
on those very basic things is the the
the very basics are not often made
explicit
which is actually what drives everybody
away from
basically any discipline but program is
just another one like even a simpler
version of the equal sign that i kind of
forget
is in mathematics equals is not
assignment
yeah like i think basically every single
programming language with just a few
handful of exceptions equals his
assignment
you have some other operator for uh
equality
yeah and you know even that like
everyone kind of knows it
once you started doing it but like you
need to say that explicitly or you just
realize it like yourself
otherwise you'll be you might be stuck
for you said like half a semester you
could be stuck for quite a long time
and i think also part of the programming
is being okay in that state of confusion
for a while it's the it's to the
debugging point it's like
i just wrote two lines of code why
doesn't this work and staring at that
for like
hours and trying to figure out
and then every once in a while you just
have to restart your computer and
everything works again and then and then
you just
kind of stare into the void with the
tear slowly rolling down your eye
by the way the fact that they didn't get
this actually had no impact on
i mean they were still able to do their
assignments right because it turns out
they're
misunderstanding wasn't being revealed
to them
yes by the problem sets we were
found actually yeah i wrote a um a
program a long time ago actually
for my master's thesis and uh in c plus
i think
or c i guess we'll see and it was uh all
memory management and terrible
um and it wouldn't work for a while
and it was some kind of it was clear to
me that it was overriding memory
and i just couldn't i was like look i i
got a paper
time for this so i basically declared a
variable
at the front in the main that was like
400k
just an array and it worked because
whenever i was scribbling over memory
it would scribble into that space and it
didn't matter and so i never figured out
what the bug was
but i did create something to sort of
deal with it to work around it
and it you know that's crazy that's
crazy it was okay because that's what i
wanted
but i knew enough about memory managed
to go you know management to go you know
i'm just going to create an empty array
here and hope that that deals with the
scribbling memory problem
and it did that takes a long time to
figure out and by the way the language
you first learned probably this garbage
collection anyway so you're not even
going to come up across you're not going
to come across that problem
you